live now to derry where the funeral of
the former sdlp leader and
nobel peace prize winner john hume has
just started this is john hoon
jr talking now and the former sdlp
leader
died on monday at the age of 83
following
a long illness um let's speak to our
senior island correspondent
david blevins um who's in london larry
um david good morning to you please
could you just give us an idea of the
significance
of this day
well it seems very unusual that we're
witnessing a
socially distanced funeral for the man
who spent his life
bringing people closer together but his
family did ask
the community not to line the streets to
light a candle at home to protect public
health
and in the last few minutes we've heard
tributes to john hume
read by the bishop of derry from pope
francis
and from the dalai lama and now we're
hearing a very personal tribute
from the family read by his son john jr
on father's day a few weeks ago as we
couldn't be with him
all his grandchildren posted him his
favorite chocolate bars
i hear they had a lovely feast and one
more
if god were here today in the fullness
of his health witnessing the current
tensions in the world
he wouldn't waste the opportunity to say
a few words himself
he'd talk about our common humanity the
need to respect diversity
and difference to protect and deepen
democracy
to value education and to place
non-violence
at the core of everything he might also
stress the need for a living wage
a roof over your head the right to
decent healthcare
and to education which was very close to
his heart
if we were if he were here now he might
quote us to his friend
congressman john lewis who sadly passed
away a few weeks ago
appealing to the goodness of every every
human being
and never giving up
dad was a dairy man to his core and
those deep roots of neighborhood
and community served to nourish him
throughout the difficult years
from the beginning the european union
was like a homecoming
bringing together diverse cultures in an
interdependent relationship
allowing for unique identities but at
the same time
holding the bigger picture of unified
kinship
at this time of planetary fragility
more than ever he would be urging that
we move beyond
our flag-based identities and recognize
that we need to protect
our common home central to dad's work
was a deep appreciation of human
interdependency
we all need one another we all have a
role to play
all our roles are of equal importance
in the last years of dad's life his
physical and mental health
became more and more visibly vulnerable
and yet in these those recent years more
than ever we as a family
witnessed the absolute importance of
dad's core ethos
of building community based on respect
and love
the kindness shown to dad by the people
of derry and donegal
they stopped to talk to him in the
street every day
guided him to protect his independence
when he was confused
and received him with gentleness when he
was agitated
was to provide a profound gift to all of
us
we are eternally grateful as a family to
all those that helped him over the years
in the last two years when he lost his
mobility and his sight
he moved to owen more nursing in this
his last home and it was a home a home
for all of us
all of us as a family were made very
welcome and became part of a new
community
of families and carers the deep
attention and love
shown to dad and to the many friends he
made amongst carers
residents and their families will remain
a lesson to us all
for the rest of our lives during the
long weeks of lockdown
when we as a family were unable to be
with them we knew
that despite the major difficulties of
infection management and bereavement
the care and nursing staff in unit one
were doing all their absolute best
to care deeply for him and for all his
fellow residents
we know that he continued to sing songs
every day to teach them all a wee bit of
french
to tell jokes to demand more bones
and to question everyone daily about
where they came from their origins and
their families
although he remembered nothing dad
remained deeply interested
in every individual he met right down to
the end of his death
dad was also a father a husband
and a man who loved and cared for his
family at all times
her mum was without a doubt dad's
greatest achievement
and she enabled him to reach his full
potential
mom and dad met at a dance and
borderland
the ballroom of romance just across the
border
in donegal the starting point for many a
dairy family
romance was followed by a wedding and a
december honeymoon
in a freezing bnb in gardner street in
dublin
for mum the quality of the accommodation
got better
as the marriage went up our mum who
loved supported and guided him
throughout his tireless work and later
in his frailty
was his greatest blessing none of us
remember him
changing nappies or indeed putting many
indeed any dinners on the table what we
do remember
are endless coffee cups and overflowing
ashtrays
newspapers everywhere and constant
stream of callers night and day
to our home and west empire but he was
there for all of us throughout our life
there were times when i think we all
felt that he was absent
but he wasn't he was just with us from
somewhere else
along with mum he taught us all our
values
and gave us all our moral comments and
for that
we will be forever in their debt
as a family we'll remember the man who
was rooted in this community
a man who was most comfortable sitting
in front of the tv
with half a dozen crunchy bars to keep
him company and his families around him
or the old-time holding court around the
corner in the park
a man who ordered the same dinner in the
same restaurants
in strasbourg and greencastle for 25
years
i'm sure he's up there now ordering his
creme brulee and off that awful sweet
wine that he loved
a man who loved darius is best be that
promoting the candy stripes across the
world
or the many choirs that he brought from
the city to europe to sing in brussels
and in strasbourg a man who himself
didn't need to be invited twice to lift
the mic
and give us a blast at the time i loved
so well our math highlands
and many many many more
a man who truly believed to derry and
the talents of our people
and became our greatest ambassador to
the world
a man who loved only god and spent most
of that time time
in bombay and green castle in movaut
where he was finally able to switch off
and relax
and get that peace and quiet that he
richly needed and deserved
the care god received in the last years
of his life
allowed him to retain his dignity
individuality
and his magnificent strength of
character despite his overwhelming
and growing disabilities it allowed him
to overcome
if you were here he would urge us all to
look at those young carers
and the incredible and heroic daily work
they do
as a model for future leadership their
ethos of deep respect
i respect for everyone regardless of
where they come from
our stage of life these are the
foundation stones
that are critical to all communities the
reverend martin luther king
might describe it as the politics of
love
dad would urge us to listen so that in
spite of it all
we shall overcome thank you dad
okay for a life well
a very personal tribute from john hume
jr speaking about his father's focus on
common humanity the need to respect
diversity and difference
to protect and deepen democracy and to
place
non-violence at the absolute center of
everything
also paying tribute of course to his
mother
pat who journeyed with john hume
the whole way through his lengthy
political career
they will be disappointed that this
cathedral cannot
be filled today but they are
honored by the presence of the irish
president the taoiseach prime minister
michael martin
and by the presence of the first and
deputy first ministers of northern
ireland arlene foster and michelle
o'neill the women who are of course
sharing the power john hume envisaged in
the devolved government
of northern ireland the women tasked
with carrying on the
task he started of building peace and
defending it
in northern ireland
john hume one of the key architects of
the northern ireland peace process the
former sdlp
leader being laid to rest today in derry
after his death last monday aged 83
following a long illness